[Música]
vamos a pasar a las noticias de la salud
de la mano de Mara Romero sala Buen día
para usted Buenos días Ángela vamos a
tener primero una noticia muy polémica
alrededor de un fármaco el llamado
osempic que últimamente se ha viralizado
para perder peso peligrosísimo además
muy muy peligroso ahora revisaremos por
qué cuáles son sus efectos por ejemplo
la etiqueta os explique en tiktok tiene
casi 600 millones de vistas de personas
que están explicando cómo lo usan y
además son muchos los famosos que están
explicando que lo están tomando
precisamente con ese propósito de perder
peso empecemos por el principio que es
que se trata este medicamento su
componente activo es decir el
medicamento en sí no el nombre comercial
es la semaglutida controla el azúcar en
sangre también los niveles de insulina y
por eso es un medicamento diseñado para
tratar la diabetes no está hecha por la
farmacéutica novo nordisk se aprobó por
la fda en Estados Unidos fuente
regulatorio en 2017 precisamente con
este propósito y además no es barato en
Estados Unidos cuesta
892 dólares sin seguro cada mes es decir
que es un medicamento bastante caro si
no se tiene una cobertura por el seguro
la polémica empieza cuando este
medicamento se usa para otros propósitos
no como estábamos diciendo por ejemplo
para perder peso no Bono Ortiz de hecho
desarrolló digamos un hermano mayor de
este medicamento de Empire llamado we
gobi ya diseñado para perder peso porque
ese vídeo que es en pic pues tenía
algunos efectos Precisamente en la
percepción del hambre reduce el apetito
y también disminuye la velocidad en la
que se vacía el estómago por lo que hay
una mayor sensación de saciedad Entonces
se ha empezado a prescribir we Go vi
aprobado por la fda que es el mismo
componente activo al final en 2021 para
perder peso y también ha sucedido que
entonces las personas si no encuentran
el y quieren perder peso o se lo
recomiendan también los médicos para
porque consideran que deben perder peso
para su salud pues entonces empiezan a
comprar o en que está diseñado para
personas diabéticas entonces hay unos
problemas ahí también de abastecimiento
Y por qué no Omar de gordofobia hablemos
de los efectos secundarios que tiene
este medicamento ahí empezamos a entrar
en una espiral como decías bien
peligrosa al principio Tiene efectos
secundarios muy fuertes estamos hablando
por ejemplo de disrupciones del tránsito
intestinal causando náuseas vómitos
diarreas pero también estreñimiento como
además reduce el nivel de azúcar en
sangre puede provocar mareos e incluso
visión borrosa y en niveles más graves
estamos hablando de que algunos de sus
efectos secundarios son la pancreatitis
que es la inflamación del páncreas
problemas con la vesícula biliar e
incluso propicia la aparición de tumores
de tiroides por eso está contraindicado
para las personas que ya estén
predispuestas a desarrollar este tipo de
cáncer o Estos tipos de tumores claro
entendemos que ese riesgo puede tener
sentido para personas diabéticas sobre
todo con diabetes tipo 2 que es la
diabetes adquirida sobrellevar algunos
de estos efectos secundarios con
vigilancia médica no con seguimiento y
acompañamiento pero a partir de ahí
entramos en un problema detonado como
bien decías por ese ver el peso como un
problema de salud en cualquier caso que
si desaparece el peso desaparecen todos
los demás problemas sin importar qué es
lo que se lleva por delante el proceso
de perder peso no Además de como decías
también las presiones estéticas que
fiscalizan esos cuerpos ajenos
básicamente solo en el peso sin ver al
final todo lo demás que puede provocar
este medicamento no por ejemplo reducir
el peso porque reduces tu hambre puede
tener muchos otros efectos además de
tener como decíamos por el tema de las
náuseas o de las diarreas que eso al
final también provoca deshidratación
tiene todos los ingredientes para
propiciar un trastorno o de conducta
alimentaria o Pues potenciarlo si ya
existía cosa que además sucede mucho es
al final en las personas que perciben su
peso como un problema al final es
destruir el cuerpo por dentro por una
exigencia estética madre y pues acá nos
sobra la recomendación es que los
medicamentos deben ser utilizados con
responsabilidad y por una justificación
médica no y con sus propósitos
originales vamos a cambiar de tema
seguro que esto de los empiecen nos va a
dar más de qué hablar en el futuro pero
por ahora quisiera cambiar radicalmente
para hablar de dos brotes de dengue que
fueron identificados en España porque es
importante este caso si es importante
que hablemos de esto porque es un
síntoma de un problema más grave ahora
lo vamos a ver primero empecemos por
dónde fuese localizó en la isla de Ibiza
en las Islas baleares y se notificaron
por Alemania a España porque se trataban
de seis turistas alemanes en dos brotes
separados de tres y tres personas que
estaban pues visitando las islas
baleares en Octubre y en septiembre de
2022 el año pasado hay un caso
confirmado un caso probable cuatro casos
compatibles y parece que empezó por un
turista que había estado en México un
país donde el dengue es endémico se
había contagiado allí lo trajo a España
y a partir de ahí empezó a contagiarse
como sabemos Pues a través de las
picaduras de mosquito que son los
vectores de esta enfermedad la principal
preocupación que España no esté teniendo
buenos niveles de notificación y de
vigilancia de esta enfermedad porque si
esos casos sucedieron en septiembre
octubre y Alemania los tuvo que
notificar a España puede ser que hayan
habido casos que hayan pasado Sin
detectarse teniendo en cuenta además que
en el 80% de los casos el dengue es
asintomático o presenta síntomas leves
es cada vez más común que se den esos
pequeños brotes en Europa no Exacto Ese
es el síntoma del que estábamos hablando
el dengue es una enfermedad Tropical es
endémica en países de América Latina en
países de África pero en la última
década han empezado a llegar con más
frecuencia al viejo continente a Europa
en 2010 fue la primera vez que hubo
contagios autóctonos no importados es
decir no que alguien se hubiera
contagiado fuera de Europa y hubiera
reportado su caso en Europa sino que la
transmisión ya hubiera sido en suelo
europeo eso fue en 2010 los primeros en
Francia y En Croacia desde entonces han
ido notificándose pues paulatinamente en
varios países por ejemplo en España los
primeros contagios autóctonos fueron en
18 Por qué sucede esto Bueno pues en los
países mediterráneos también a raíz de
las últimas dinámicas climáticas y de
expansión de las especies ha llegado el
mosquito tigre llegó el
mosquito tigre que es un mosquito
compatible también con la transmisión
del dengue estos vectores ya están
asentados aquí desde hace años si llegan
casos importados es muy probable que
sigan habiendo pues pequeños brotes que
vayan surgiendo en varios países sobre
todo de la zona Mediterráneo y además
con el cambio climático puede ser que
estos límites que por ahora están en esa
zona mediterránea de Europa sigan
subiendo más al norte si pues hay las
temperaturas y las condiciones adecuadas
para que estos mosquitos lleguen a otros
territorios mal que vienen en América la
tiene el Caribe estamos más adaptados y
más alertas para detectar estas
enfermedades O sea que de ahí también
otra gran importancia de estos casos
gracias a usted muchas gracias